офіс президента з ним працював і хотів
показати президента таким собі черчелим
єдиним героєм а Шустер його сприймав так
як він його бачить а не так як хоче його
показати офіс президента а він його
бачить таким е розгубленим людиною яка є
на грані програшу яка не може відкрито
зрозуміти що відбувається чому Цей
програш може відбутися я в Цей програш
очевидно не вірю тому що це абсолютно
суб'єктивне сприйняття цього журналіста
але коли він наприклад розповідає Що з
офісу президента керують там
хочуть звільнити тих чи інших військових
керують наступом очевидно для
демократичної країни це виглядає дико
він виглядає таким воваждем якогоськ
племені який може бути успішним або може
бути неуспішним а не лідером
демократичної країни